welcome
[Music]
[Music]
back chosen for a reason what if i told
you that val was putting a team together
to stop a group of super soldiers bent
on creating chaos throughout the mcu
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitched the wildest theories for the
nerdy titles that we love my name is mt
and going with me today is titania's
favorite pr representative it's jessica
clemens what's going on jess hi
hi
i was looking at the screen
i'm looking at the screen i need to i'll
put it on this screen it's i have two
monitors or maybe if i turn this monitor
closer
you're suffering from success too many
more
i want a third one i want a third one
i'm not trying to brag i'm not trying to
brag but i got too much
you got a third monitor at your feet so
when you look down yeah i just step on
it it's for my feet
and of course we've got ourselves a
super soldier that we just woke up from
cryosleep it's tom michaelson what's
going on tom hello thank you for reading
all these the words for my red book i'm
ready for uh what is my mission
homecoming
sunday garfield freight train you're
gonna say
right train yes
monday
um
and of course we got the veep of val's
thunderbolts it's brandon barrick what's
going on brandon oh that's right baby
always the vice never the prez you know
what i mean
one day always the vice
that's the best place to be you never
want to be at the top uh you don't want
to be the king you want to be the hand
of the king you know what i mean you got
to you got to you want to be at the top
if there's anything we heard about being
the hand of the king it's not good not
good no it always works out well it
works out well for every hand what are
you talking about you get your head on
this bike you get your head on a spike
or you just get fired and your daughter
is now the queen
hey season ain't over
any day
all right guys let's get into our first
topic because i have a feeling that the
thunderbolts are going to be fighting a
group of super soldiers and with zemo's
help specifically and here's why i think
this remember in civil war when we saw
that uh zemo killed all those super
soldiers because hydra just had these
really crazy super soldiers with like
the best killers that hydra has ever had
in cryo sleep i think that um
considering what we know from what if
that zemo has multiple installations of
like himself across the world i think
that there are more super soldiers that
um hydra has around the world and those
super soldiers woke up and they're gonna
cause crazy chaos in the mcu i think
that the thunderbolts could potentially
be um a team that is assembled to battle
all of these super soldiers that um we
sort of didn't really see enough of in
civil war because they just got killed
immediately so what do you guys think
this
so you think it's more of more super
soldiers but not more zemos it's it's
more more random super soldiers like in
winter soldiers yeah
i think that like zemo would hate the
superstar because he hates the concept
of super soldiers and i think that this
is why i believe that zemo was going to
cameo in this thunderbolts movie because
they're going to need the ultimate super
soldier killer for help because they
don't have them on the team it's just
like we got um we got the other black
widow we got
hey
technically taskmaster is another black
widow there's a ton of other black
widows this is true that's true she's
the other two black widows
that would be a good macguffin if like
the thunderbolts have to fight you know
they freed all these black widows and
some of them maybe went to you know go
have a nice peaceful life but we know
some of them are still out there
fighting we saw them fighting uh in
shangxi right what if like although all
the some of the black widows get
together and they're like yo we should
run this world we know how to do this
now our awful
horrible
boss is dead thank god thank god that
child trafficker is dead
yeah but it could be that like fighting
a bunch of like black widows if they
were like trying to be like no we're
just going to take over the world now
because uh we hate everybody and our
lives were ruined yeah i would i would
love that so much like specifically
because like we know that um the next
wasp in um in the marvel comics comes
from the red room so i just want to see
more red room action um there so i would
love if they were fighting the red room
as well like the the remnants of the red
room because uh they they i could see
the they want to take over the world yes
men are in charge and men are the worst
now we need women in charge to take over
yeah especially highly trained assassins
at
uh who could be in sync getting up with
their guns doing movies yeah yeah i
would just like some peaceful people to
be in charge of the world that would be
nice
i do think you're onto something though
mt because this this thunderbolts team
is really like suspicious it's really
suss right right it's mostly
uh hand-to-hand fighters uh that are
in a ton of soldiers right we have a ton
of soldiers on this team which does make
it seem like it's less like
we're making another avengers team right
where it's like a mix of powers yeah
ghost has some like interesting uh
powers to bring to the mix and like so
does taskmaster but still it's a lot of
like hand-to-hand fighting soldiers
right which i really like and it does
seem like we're missing yeah where's
zemo where's abomination where's some of
these other strange ones um
but
i it does seem like they want a team of
soldiers that are good at doing like
undercover work secretive black op style
work and them killing more of these
super soldiers would be important i feel
like it does need like something else
but then they would have to kill i think
that um i like the idea of baron zemo
being like them incorporating him to
come after super soldiers i know that
he's friends with bucky now so i don't
think he's gonna actually outwardly hurt
bucky but guardian and johnny mayonnaise
and he has a real reason to hate johnny
mayonnaise so that's why i don't really
i don't know if i see him working with
them my whole idea which i know this is
your rogue theory but i'm going to
snatch it real quick my whole idea was
the idea that uh once something happens
the vowel that's when baron zemo comes
in and is like you guys can come fight
with me where my intentions are clear
and honest unlike hers so which ones are
going to be and there's going to be
people that swap to him and some that
stay with val
um i i believe that more happening but i
i don't hate your idea like it's a rogue
theory that i like so yeah yeah i like
it too i think that there's um i think
that it makes sense if if the
thunderbolts are going to be val's kind
of uh deep ops people compared to the
suicide squad for marvel like cleaning
up a lot of messes having more super
soldiers around makes a lot of sense you
know that that need to get it needed to
be taken out and even if it's black
widows like brandon that's great too
it's like again they need to clean up
the messes that you know the us
government has has made you know our
shield has made and it makes sense for
them to go out and do that and for them
being more punchy superheroes make sense
too heck and three of them are captain
america prototypes even you know like uh
there could be three shields on this
team of six people with taskmaster
uh red guardian and uh us agents so they
could be just anti-captain america you
know guys coming around and maybe yeah
then so
i like what just was saying is that with
zemo yeah he may not want to work with
them so him coming in as
uh again compared to suicide squad is
like a joker like maybe another per
antagonist potentially that they either
team up with or don't team up with i
think would make the movie a lot more
interesting
i like it i don't want i'll be super i
don't want them to redeem my boy zemo
he's been too nice lately i want to be
going back to being evil
like it is so weird that he's not
involved yet with thunderbolts that we
know of i feel like they're hiding some
stuff from us i don't think they've
shown us the full team yet but i would
love like some reveal like he's such a
mastermind and he does hate super
soldiers if he was like using val to get
all these super soldiers together so he
could ultimately take them out or if val
is revealed to be zemo's sister and
she's also pissed off and now they're
working together to like take over the
world
there's so many theories hold on let me
get this [ __ ] that's crazy
i love it that's great
you're gonna be wild i would love that
so much man i want my boy
i think val is smarter than zemo and i
am saying that from
the point of also a woman but it's like
zemo yeah he was and this is also like
okay think on the big picture kind of
scope of thing
zema was able to get those uh the civil
war basically able to get them to fight
each other he's not the only one who
ever beat the avengers
but the avengers are a bunch of goons
there are a bunch of doesn't matter so
like he [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying val could val easily could if
that would have been so easy going in
that it would have been quicker if it
was val i think just because it was like
a bunch of dumb boys fighting and
starting [ __ ] and then unfortunately
hold on hold on yeah
oh dumb boys those are my boys those are
my boys
i think they're done oh we saw i don't
want to be that person but we saw the
way that tony reacted immediately
to finding out did this man murdered his
parents i get it but also you have to
stay grounded yourself calm down tony
you're being a superhero everybody
you're a superhero you every parent dies
if you're a superhero you choked out his
mom he woke up
my next thought would be like okay he
was brainwashed a b
uh who let me name all my superhero
friends whose parents died everyone
everyone yeah everyone yeah
you know what peter parker did to the
man who killed uncle ben he killed that
man he killed that he saved that's what
i'm talking about
but on may he saved them he said no wait
which side
which peter parker
this man's mentally ill let me help him
no that's what he tells people what he
did was hold that man's head under water
until he stopped breathing this is why i
didn't want you on rogue theory
you were gonna come with this i gotta
deal with you every day i don't care if
you're brainwashed you murder my parents
it's on site there we go
that's god i
mean i get it but i'm also a superhero i
have to keep more calm than normal
civilians it's like true it's true
great power great responsibility yeah
yeah yeah but if it's my mom that's what
i'm talking about that's what i'm
talking about
exactly it's fun because it's not my mom
it was like brandon's mom i'm gonna say
brandon calm down chill out dude
if it's martha oh we all going ham now
we're all going crazy why'd you say that
name
but i can actually see val wanting to
clean up the world of super soldiers
because especially if because i have
this theory that val herself is hydra i
think that val is secretly working for
hydra and um red skull's new world order
and since these uh super soldiers in
civil war were hydra's problem like they
they were revolting against hydra um i
think that hydra wants to clean up their
own mess it's like we made this mess so
let's just pretend like we're the good
guys and we're gonna like take get rid
of these super soldiers that we made a
long time ago whoops um so i have a
feeling that um val could actually be
just trying to do damage control for
hydra it's like all right we have our
own type of super soldiers or the
thunderbolts let's get rid of these
other guys because they're no longer of
use to us um so i don't know just a
weird
theory on another weird theory um but no
let's do it let's do our voting now
because uh what do you guys think of
this theory of the thunderbolts fighting
a group of super soldiers from hydra in
cryostasis that have been awakened like
tom michelson
for the first time in 70 years
i love this yeah this is this is great i
think it's a lot of fun and it makes a
lot of sense with what kind of heroes
are getting together again like the
punchier kind like what kind of threats
they can take on because it's not like
they're going to fight galactus or
something like that so um yeah we don't
know that we don't know maybe you come
come back and watch it come back and put
the comments if i'm wrong like four
years from now or whatever but uh yeah
no i love it i think it's great i think
it's a lot of fun and it got us talking
a lot about i mean brandon and jessica
came up with great theories too off the
cuff of that you know which were all
okay and so it inspires a lot of really
fun ideas so i like it rogues all right
so rocus from tom what do you guys what
do you guys think i would um i'm
i'm
i'm a i'm a person
that's right not a superhero but a
person i'm not
i'm a person i'm a normal person i'm a
girl i put my jeans on i'm not a girl
one arm at a time like everybody else
and
i i'm like that person that's like if
you're giving me like a meaty substance
i don't care
how crazy it is but it's meaty and that
what you gave me was the rogue rogue
very meat it was a meat stew heavy irish
dude so i'm gonna go rogues i'm here for
it all right two rogues i'll take it
brandon yeah
i will opposite because he's an animal
sorry keep going i am an animal it's
true i am not a person i'm an animal
born born in the swamp
pulled myself right now what they would
say yeah yeah man thing by day
by night baby uh
i've got it all your poor wife
my poor my poor
wife brought into the streets animal of
the sheep that's right todd
she was born she was warned
she'd do it she's getting it uh i will
give this theory a rogus because i do i
do think
the the super soldier is like the
biggest mcguffin in marvel they still
deal with it in the comics it is still a
big deal uh and i think falcon and
winter soldier of the show showed us
that like it ain't over yet there's
always going to be people trying to make
it you know she-hulk's getting there
with the blood and stuff like yeah i
think i think i like this idea of like
the thunderbolts
being used to like kill off a bunch of
super soldiers because the government
knows it needs to happen and they need
like a team to get dirty to do it so
yeah i like that 100 i like that
all right three ropes says whoa thanks
guys i love sharing
my theories and hearing your theories
you guys are so smart the smartest
people i know but up next down speaking
of smart people jessica has a rogue
theory of her own that is pretty pretty
interesting but first please be sure to
head on over to newrockstarsmerge.com
where you can grab our newest latest
obsession merch lady justice inspired by
the she-hulk series this limited edition
shirt will not be available forever it's
not going to be here forever that's
what's like with all of our shirts
they're not going to be over here
forever so when you and when you
purchase it you unlock the ability to
get a custom shout out that will appear
on our inside marvel after show hosted
by me mt eric boss and the lovely
jessica clements so check out our latest
obsession shirt and all of our other
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
but we also want to thank bluechu for
sponsoring this video bluechu can help
give you that extra bit of confidence
when it matters most bluechu is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viabra and cialis
but in chewable form and at a fraction
of the cost and you can take them
anytime day or night as long as you're
not in public and so you can plan ahead
or be ready whenever an opportunity
arises and the process is simple sign up
at bluetooth.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days not weeks days
and the best part it's all done online
so no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations about you know
weird sex stuff and no waiting in line
at the pharmacy blue chews tablets are
made in the usa usa and prepared and
shipped direct to your door in a
discrete package and we've got a special
deal for our listeners try bluetooth for
free when you use our promo code rogue
at checkout just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
rogue to receive your first month for
free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast and video um but jess
hit us with our second topic of today
because i know it's going to be meaty
real real meaty one
yes
yes
um remember what i said earlier about it
doesn't matter if it makes sense it's
just really good immediate let's keep
that in mind when i pitch this theory so
so
in the 2000 i mean mt talked about this
briefly but i'm going to bring it up
again
in 2014 there's a lovely uh comic of
she-hulk great run great time to be
alive uh
and in this comic the third issue is a
man that comes to her name kristoff
that's like i don't want to go back home
i don't want to go back home i hate my
dad i want to get asylum here in the
united states and i just want to stay
here and never go back he is a rich boy
he is a playboy he doesn't care about
anyone else but himself and ladies
and he is also the son to dr doom
and i think this character has already
been shown in the mcu because i think
this guy
is todd in the she-hulk series
so
i think
we clearly know todd is up to no good we
already saw the fifth episode of
she-hulk and i'm sorry i'm about to
spoil a little bit of things right here
right is that okay
is that okay to do that's the i mean you
already gave the spoiler warning so
you're good to go oh okay good so we
know that we know that todd is already
coming off as like a man that's uh
demanding who thinks he owns the room
who owns basically kind of women he's uh
when he talks about she-hulk he's like
yeah we went on this date she confided
in me i'm a great guy girls deserve me
which is the exact same kind of outward
like
vibe that kristoff gives in the comics
he always still hits on she-hulk 24 7
knowing that that's his lawyer and he
just constantly just wants to spend his
money and hang out and be stupid but
never actually go back to la verria to
live with his dad and so i think this
could be our inter introduction of
doctor doom into the mcu via his son and
i think it would be a great way to start
it because we know that he's making
money somehow todd is very rich i don't
think he just became rich randomly he
had to become rich from family and i
think that family is that
world away that's la veria and whether
or not it's like
we jump time or we come back or what
have you i just think that it'd be funny
that there is already a lot of area that
exists doctor doom is already there and
he'll come eventually and be like
where's my son
where's my son where's my son give me
back my sister give me back where's my
son harry potter my boy
that's my son
um i want him
and that's what he does in the comics he
shows up on the court date he wasn't
invited to the court date because it was
honestly only for kristoff to get asylum
so it was just basically international
laws and he bust through the freaking
ceiling and he's like my son is here and
playing games give him back to me and
they're like you can't do this that's
against the law so i think this could be
todd is doctor doom son
wow that would be absolutely wild i
would my job would be to the ground like
that would be the ultimate introduction
the most hilarious introduction of
doctor doobie just crashes in through
the ceilings like give me that much it's
like the green kool-aid man oh no
oh yeah
the only like it sucks because we
haven't seen too much of todd we know
that uh at d23 he did mention that his
character is basically an uh an iron man
wannabe and kristoff is basically that
kristoff is like super like obnoxious in
the like arrogant sense where he's just
like
yeah whatever i don't care i don't want
it but i do want you and he hits on
shell like tons and tons and tons of
times and she says no every time but
it's still a man that thinks he like
owns a lot so i think that could be todd
this is great i think there's also no
like i think there's also a chance that
even if this doesn't get revealed in
she-hulk this could come out down the
line in another way too because they
could be just having him in the
background being some random character
but it's not too out there i mean just
from the end credits alone and that cool
one of those cool drawings if you saw
all the shoes
like they had um a thing shoe
you know they had like different shoes
from different marvel characters i've
yet to show up and you know there was
such a quick glance maybe they had uh i
didn't see and i haven't watched just
just his breakdown yet sorry jess but um
you know there might have been a doctor
doom shoe in there again like they've
set up all these they set up they they
have they're setting up that these
characters exist in this world
so i love that that's a really
interesting theory that i think would
make a lot of sense my breakdown also
hasn't come out yet it will have been
coming out by the time this video drops
but it has knocked out there you're not
watching it
ice cream i like busting me out just
trying to play it cool be like oh you
know i haven't seen it yet because you
know it's the future now but all right
cool
i could say i've watched it several
times jessica
from all of my accounts
i hit the like button on each of my
accounts
i several you do
guaranteed guaranteed guaranteed i like
this jessica uh why do we think he's
going after the blood so much is it is
it just for his own personal gain or is
it like i think maybe he's trying to get
back into his dad's good graces
i like the
usurp the throne i i genuinely like mt's
actual theory about where the blood why
it's the blood i think i think yeah it
would be funny if he's like i need this
to get back in my dad's good graces
because in the comic book he was running
away from his dad but we know that
they're not staying so close to the
comic book so it would be funny if he's
like trying to go back and see his dad
but his dad liked his own
i love the idea
i love the idea of like big powerful
scary magic wielding doctor doom and
then just like this dweeb
todd who's like
a smarmy little worm who's like not
smooth at all like it's like seventh
grade you're evil he's like so
embarrassed by it
i wish i was never cryogenically made in
his two yeah his dad's just like jesus
christ i let you go to america i was
hoping yeah yeah stay there
i'd rather hang out with my doombots
go get yourself a nemesis
are you wearing a scarf a fashion yeah
you're wearing this stylist yeah
something short
honestly i think that would be very
funny it'd give the little comedic-ness
to dr doom i'm gonna be looking for him
to wear any green now just to see if
there's any hints of them
right that and um
or maybe he needs the blood just because
his dad does have powers and he doesn't
so he's probably like
i want powers i want to be this and if i
had to honestly not to again to rag on
boys but like i feel like a boy that is
rich and powerful that sees like the
superhero he likes like hulk and being
like
i could pay to be that yeah yeah like
like
a veruca salt just like i want like i i
don't know if i would do that like be
like scarlet witch give it to me it's
like no it doesn't work like that
her powers are a lot to deal with no
thank you
oh yeah that's what i'd wanted because
you can make yourself fly sometimes and
then you can make there's other heroes
that can fly without all the baggage
chaos magic
i want a girlfriend like scarlet witch
because if i were to die i want her to
make a big stink about it no i wanted to
just
completely transform new jersey
i can't wait to die don't wake me back
up let me go keep bringing you back to
life please kill me please
let me die
kill me
kill me please if i was scarlet witch i
would just be like making sandwiches all
the time like i really want a sandwich
and then just like you know your cat
turns into a sandwich and you're like
well i guess i'll eat it i guess
[Laughter]
we're all made of the same materials
they're just structured in a different
way we're the same as a sandwich so you
need a human i would a human a human is
just atoms it's just atoms molecules
you've seen eight spiders in your life
and you've probably eaten some human
dust so it's happening thank you the
amount the longer i work at new rock
stars the longer you guys reveal
yourself to be insane
you're not telling me you're literally
telling me
you're telling me at the hot dog factory
every now and then a dude doesn't fall
into the hot dog machine exactly they
don't catch it in time same time you
just eat and do sometimes
so all those horrible boys just talking
about it's us right here she's like by
the way i've been trying to give you
guys hints it's y'all that are listening
it's all you
if there's no ninjas
you guys would be so stupid and i would
be the one and i would be the one that
has to answer the door get the phone do
it be like branded you do your laundry
uh mt did you put your dishes in the
sink tom will you stop uh pooping on the
floor like
i keep my makeup there also geez
thank you thank you tom thank you oh
that's hilarious yeah you know just but
if it's your mom just okay all of a
sudden story's different just saying
jesse
i believe that
but no i i really love this theory like
myself i'm gonna give this theory a
rogus because like my goodness would it
be wild to see dr doob's son just being
an actual like doofus and like dr doom
just being ashamed just being like well
this is i have no idea how this is my
son um i don't know
where my genes are in this boy it's not
it doesn't exist
do you guys do paternity testing yeah
it's like no this is a law firm
so i'm going to give justice theory a
big old double rogus because it's extra
rogue it's very meaty it's amazing
rogue with um comic book um bases so
like i like it
yeah i'm gonna go i'm gonna go rogue on
this one too even though i feel attacked
as a boy but you know you got some good
points there jess and i do feel like
this rook theory became an intervention
on all the things we do wrong but
but
you're totally right that this that that
i could see that happening and that's so
much fun if that were true and it would
be again like i even think like i was
saying earlier this if it's not revealed
now it could come later and that would
just give she-hulk as the show a lot
more context and weight and gravitas
that i would love to see so
wrote rogues from vogue for me over here
what do you think brandon i will also
give this theory
i really like it
i do not think it's gonna come true but
i love it it's not no no no i don't
think they have the guts i don't think
they have the guts to do it i mean i
would they're cowards because
dare you if they revealed doctor doom on
she-hulk the cojones it would take to do
that would be impressive uh i wish they
would but hulk size i like them with
space i'll give a rogues
[Laughter]
submerged cities the salmon wouldn't
know which way to go upstream
total chaos cats and dogs together
yeah
oh my god i love you guys but now it is
time for our rogue questions you guys
ready for this one yes
let's get it because mr pedro pascal the
mandalorian himself the father of grogu
said in an interview this week that he
would love for his co-star from the
unbearable weight of massive talent
nicholas cage to be in the star wars
universe so what is the romance role
that you would like to see nicholas cage
play in a star wars project
i mean i think
i think nicholas cage as like a protocol
droid would be so great you wouldn't be
able to see his face as the problem but
if it was just like
like how they had you know ultron was so
much james spader that i loved it so
much like a very nicholas cage style
protocol droid would be great but i will
also pitch one of my favorite characters
we've yet to see in the live action who
came from the shadows of the empire
novel
uh prince she's she's or himself
uh nicholas cage has princess z she's or
she's or i don't even know who that is
she's he's like this big green alien
who's like very rich and wealthy and his
power is that like he can he releases
pheromones
uh and so like he gets his way all the
time because you can't resist him and
like even princess leia like can't
resist like variables
like real nicholas kate
he's just this like wealthy essential
eccentric alien and i think uh
uh nicholas cage would play a great
great prince she's or oh absolutely
absolutely i would love that
what do you guys think um my um
let's see i was thinking it would be
great to have him in one of the most
iconic some of the iconic roles like he
could he could do darth vader uh you
know it was just his voice all the time
where and you know he could come out and
he could be like but it's like con aaron
nicholas was like don't touch the
combination and just imagining him
someone could do that go go and make a
dubbed version of vader all vader lines
with nicholas cage lines that would be
great or yeah i would love to see him
like on musa farm
we're gonna be like wait is he did he
does he like this and we don't know and
that's we get nicholas from ghost rider
and nicholas cage from kick ass
yes
yeah that's what i that's what i want to
see yeah either that or him just painted
green and he could be grogu and just not
even say a word for now oh my god just
float in a little thing yeah and then
give looks here and there's a grown man
because didn't he do a movie recently
he
didn't say a word is that um
yeah it was uh was it that uh chuck e
cheese uh
yeah it was uh
the play oh my god dude give me a freaky
i know i'm gonna kill my uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna be so mad if i fred is it
freddy frey
freaky freddy's no
friday night freddy's freddy no willie's
wonderland willie's wonderland that's
what it is thank you jess thank you oh
thank god he got two months
drinking chugging a beer yeah
yeah so he's already showing he can go
whole movie without talking so he could
do a baby grogan too so i say yeah
either burning his vader on musicfire or
or
just painted green
um all right i love it what do you think
jess i think that it should be nicholas
cage as
ghost writer as general creepers
general crevasses
[Laughter]
so the only ghost rider part of it is
just the face i actually know yeah
because i wanted to be face painted
nicolas cage because you know helen goes
rider he was like paint my face before
they did this
so i just wanted the face painted him
and i want him to do his best general
grievous is fun he'll have fun he likes
it he's like fun
oh totally and like my biggest complaint
with um nicholas cage's performances is
that he's only had two arms on his
entirety
and uh
he's just he needs more arms four of
them spinning at the same time yeah that
would be the best kind of cage there is
come on man my joints can't do that i
can barely even move my joints
these are all amazing answers as always
but i'm gonna have to give the rogue
question trophy to mr tom michaelson
because i just want to see
um
honestly oh no that would be hilarious
yeah yeah
and bernie of course but not the real
nicholas case him as atticus yes because
he's done that quite a lot um being on
fire so like why not one more but that
is it for this like really off the rails
episode of rogue theory i love each and
every one of you jessica clements tom
michaelson brandon barrick thank you for
joining us today support all of them on
twitter go follow them wherever they are
and just to support whatever they do and
you can support our channel by checking
out all of our awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.comnot.org.com we are
a company and if you got some thoughts
on some rogue theories of your own you
can share them on our discord so if
you're over 18 search for new rockstars
discord server and just join the
conversation because we want to hear
from you you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] follow me
rockstars on all social media platforms
and be sure to subscribe to our channel
here on youtube we love you guys so much
thank you guys for spending time with us
it means a lot to us every time and
we'll see you guys next time goodbye bye
see ya
do i suck brandon oh
[Music]
you